This is really funny.
So last week when I was teasing the bonus
show, previewing the stories on the bonus
show, I had a verbal slip and I called it
the bonus show and we chose not to edit it
out because we don't edit the show.
We actually do.
The show is just we just film it.
And that's the show.
And it was sort of funny.
And there were expectedly memes and there
were songs and remixes and all this different
stuff.
But there are now lots of callers who are
casually referring to it as the bonus show
and voicemails.
And that's not even like the main point of
the call.
And I have one such call today about that.
But this is actually really, really interesting.
The other day and I took the New York Times
dialect quiz, I mentioned having friends from
the South who claim I have a New York accent.
And sometimes people call into the show and
say, I have a Boston accent, but I don't have
either.
I didn't grow up in Boston or New York and
I did this New York Times dialect quiz and
it came back saying, I have a southern western
New England accent primarily, which is accurate.
That's exactly where I grew up.
And that I have elements of my dialect in
English that are typically from Yonkers, New
York, and Pembroke Pines, Florida.
Now, I hypothesized, I wonder if there is
some aspect of what is sometimes called the
Jewish American dialect that would be centered
around Yonkers and Pembroke Pines.
That has kind of that.
There are traces of it in my speech.
And this caller, who, again, casually refers
to the bonus show as the bonus show, has a
different explanation for those elements of
my speech.
Take a listen.
This is really interesting.
Hey, David, I was listening to your show the
other day, and you were talking about how
you took the quiz to determine your dialect.
Yes.
And I believe that one of the things it's
important to you to be having a dialog from
the Pembroke Pines, Florida area.
Well, I have an office in terms of times.
I'm familiar with the area.
And I believe you attributed that to perhaps
your Jewish heritage.
But I would like to set the record straight.
Please, please.
Pembroke Pines is has a very high Hispanic
population, about over 40 percent Hispanic,
primarily college educated, mostly from South
America.
So I believe that may be where that hint of
dialect may come from.
So that is very, very interesting.
And in fact, if you look at Pembroke Pines,
at Yonkers, New York, which is the other place
where my my accent has traces, has roots,
there's also a large Hispanic population in
Yonkers.
So that may be accurate.
And I was thinking back, you know, when I
first moved to the United States, I only knew
two words.
I knew the word stop and I knew the word blue.
And I remember leaving JFK Airport and seeing
a stop sign.
What are the odds, you know, a five year old
me, what are the odds that right away I see
a word that I know this is going to go really,
really easily.
It's going to be great.
And of course, it was difficult.
But the early folks when I was in school,
they had, you know, sort of like helpers.
This is when schools, I think, were maybe
better funded and there was more staffing.
But some of the other kids who were learning
English coming from Spanish speaking countries,
there were sort of like helpers who spoke
English with accents.
They were native Spanish speakers who spoke
And I wonder my early English exposure, other
than Mr. Rogers, was my parents who speak
English with an accent sourced from Spanish
language and the helpers at school who would
have that exact same accent in English, having
learned English as a second language.
So I believe that this caller may very much
be on to something very, very much be on to
something.
OK, that's it.
I went on for a long time, but that's the
story on today's bonus show.
Texas has now sued four different states over
election results to try to overturn the election
for Donald Trump.
Does Texas even have standing to sue other
states?
We will talk about that on today's bonus show.
Australia is going to make Facebook and Google
pay news outlets for content.
How will that work?
We will discuss it.
And Rudy Giuliani, I mean, think about the
absurdity of this.
Rudy Giuliani yesterday went on a rant against
masks and against covid restrictions from
his hospital room where he is being treated
for coronavirus, which he caught by not wearing
a mask and traveling around the country.
It's beyond belief.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman dotcom coupon code available.
If you want it fresh, start or get access
to the bonus show by becoming a patron at
Dot Dotcom The David Pakman Show.